el hospital shifa en la ciudad de gaza
ya estaba realmente mal preparado para
hacer frente al coronavirus ahora bajo
la doble presión de una pandemia y la
guerra con israel el mayor hospital de
la franja de gaza está luchando para
manejar la afluencia masiva de pacientes
con áfrica este departamento se
convirtió en una unidad de cuidados
intensivos con 10 camas para hacer
frente al coronavirus pero desde que
israel empezó a atacar gaza se ha vuelto
a cambiar ahora está reservado para los
pacientes heridos en los ataques
desde que comenzó la escalada bélica el
número de camas de cuidados intensivos
se ha duplicado hasta llegar a 32 pero
no es ni mucho menos suficiente los 13
hospitales de la franja de gaza apenas
pueden recibir suministros de
medicamentos y combustible desde que
israel impuso un bloqueo en junio de
2007 israel por su parte niega haber
impedido que los suministros
humanitarios lleguen a los hospitales
dice que la culpa de la escasez la tiene
el movimiento islamista hamás pero con
el territorio bajo las bombas de 'noche
y día' los funcionarios sanitarios
advierten de una catástrofe humanitaria
cada día vemos más muertes vemos más
destrucción vemos más heridos graves en
fuerza y lo peor de todo es que la
destrucción de las infraestructuras
básicas está impidiendo el acceso de los
heridos graves a los centros sanitarios
muchos funcionarios sanitarios afirman
que tras semanas de combates la
destrucción ya es peor que los daños que
dejó la última gran guerra de 2014